after eight years of war could Yemen
really be on the brink of Peace where
the first foreign journalists inside
Yemen since Iran and Saudi Arabia the
two Regional Powers who fueled this war
agreed to renew diplomatic ties and we
bring you a series of exclusive reports
from across the country
[Music]
thank you
this conflicts often called the world
forgotten War unlike what's happening in
Ukraine this brutal Civil War has raged
here for almost a decade and much of it
without the world's attention despite it
plunging tens of millions of people into
the world's worst humanitarian crisis
and worst of all it is a totally
avoidable man-made catastrophe one of
the main reasons for This Disaster is
because of the difficulty getting into
the country so that we can tell you
what's happening here but we've got rare
access inside Yemen and we can tell you
there is not a corner of this
extraordinary place which hasn't been
impacted by conflict over the last two
weeks me and my Sky News team have
traveled hundreds of kilometers across
Yemen from the devastated divided city
of Taz to the West Coast where hundreds
of thousands have fled fighting and to
here and the port city of Aden
in this special program we have
astonishing evidence of how corruption
greed and Desperation have led to food
Aid being bought and sold just to
survive whilst thousands starve to death
this is an image which should shame
she's the face of hunger in Yemen's
forgotten War
her name is Ahad and she's three years
old but weighs less than an average
newborn
she has slowly starving to death and the
medics in this remote basic Clinic can't
seem to save her
whatever food we give her her father
says she keeps throwing it up she can't
keep it down
her father's brought her in for more
checks our head also has Down syndrome
which the Medics here have rarely seen
before
the checks confirm what's painfully
obvious
ahead is Raising red flags with every
measurement
but the nearest hospital is around 60
kilometers away and it'll cost 16 for
transport Way Beyond their means she
won't be gone
and there are tens of thousands of
children like ahard in Yemen also
starving and poor
Yemen's eight-year long War has caused
Millions to flee their homes to camps
like al-jasha on the west coast it's one
of the biggest with nearly 9 000 people
all living here from hand to mouth where
everyone seems to be hungry
within seconds of arriving we were
surrounded by people begging for food
and help
you don't even have a morsel not a bit
of rice to eat he says we have nothing
we are suffocating here we are dying
the camp is a Dusty sprawling Community
where the war is never far away
and where the arrival of a new baby
means just another mouth to feed in the
midst of a conflict which has left them
homeless
around us she says it's really scary and
it's raining bullets so how can we go
home where can we go
our presence here has attracted a big
crowd from the camp
Ing we keep telling them we're not an
aid agency we're just journalists but
they're not listening
Yemen's enduring one of the world's
worst humanitarian disasters and these
are the people who are trying to survive
it
the Coca market nearby is packed with
people trying to find a way to eat and
we find evidence of shopkeepers selling
food Aid this is quite clearly world
food program it says on it and also not
for sale
he says it was the cheapest he could
find
he agrees to lead us to the store he
bought it from but says there are plenty
more selling food Aid the shopkeeper
seems very camera shy at first
he initially denies he's got any more
food Aid he's selling in the store
yeah no not here he says and then tries
to hide a wfp packet in front of him
but with our camera rolling he realizes
it's a tough claim to pull off and
finally hands the food packet to me
remember this food is donated free and
meant for the most needy yeah world food
program again he's got a whole load of
those excuse me who's out the way please
all from the world food program how much
are you selling these for sir he's
making 700 reals or 70 cents a packet
700. do you know this is not meant to be
sold
yes he nods he knows he's not meant to
be selling donated Goods why are you
selling it then he's worried now and
says he's going to stop selling foodaid
from today
but looking around his store it's packed
with sacks of rice and flour which have
also come from International donors but
he insists he's providing a service
sell their food Aid out of desperation
says for example if someone wants to buy
medicine they sell the aid to me so they
can afford the medicine it's in an
emergency
but the small baby clinic in Kroger run
mostly by volunteers is packed with
babies and mothers who urgently need
food they cannot afford
seven-month-old Sarah is the youngest of
seven all of them are hungry but the
baby is suffering most the doctor fears
the worst if she isn't taken to hospital
there'll be complications if she doesn't
go he says and if there are
complications she'll die for sure
the doctors say Sarah needs urgent help
but her mother can't afford the fare to
the hospital so won't go
urgent doesn't come in reals or dollars
and Fatima has six other children to
feed these are choices no mother wants
to make
Sarah's fate now seemed horribly sealed
she's another young victim in Yemen's
man-made humanitarian catastrophe
foreign
that is the tragedy unfolding in just
one area of Yemen across the country
there are similar Tales of Despair and
Desperation in a moment we'll take you
to the heart of this horrific conflict
and the City of Taz once Yemen's capital
of culture now a place where sniper fire
rockets and unexploded bombs kill and
maim women and children every day so how
did Yemen find itself in this
catastrophic situation and just how
severe is this crisis
while the war in Yemen has been going on
for eight long years the latest U.N
estimates suggest 227
000 people have died in this war most of
those deaths are from the indirect
consequences of the war widespread
famine diseases like cholera and a lack
of Health infrastructure the war is
being fought between on the one hand
houthi Rebels who are backed by Iran and
have taken control of the north of the
country including the capital Sana and
Yemen's former government which is
backed by a saudi-led coalition that
includes the U.S and UK both sides have
been accused of war crimes by multiple
human rights groups we've traveled to
the front lines in Taz in the south of
the country emblematic of the divisions
and disaster here to show you what life
is like for those living in a city under
siege
we're given a two-vehicle government
Army escort to head towards the besieged
city of Taz
litten too for most of the past eight
years of war with most key roads into
and out blocked off by fighting
civilians with the houthi militia held
to one half of the City by government
troops who control the other
the city has been blasted to bits in
places with booby trap bombs buried in
gardens by the retreating Fighters and
mines hidden in kitchen ovens to blow up
any returning residents they've been
planted down Alleyways and left in the
piles of rubble and rubbish
The Siege has brought parts of Taz to
the brink of starvation yet families are
still living here
Muhammad shows us around the bombed out
shopping center which is now his home
his family is living in the basement
a lot of damage to every floor that
we've visited so far a lot of hits on
just this building alone
over there is one of the houthi bases
Muhammad tells us it's by the old
presidential Palace it's from there
snipers pick off civilians or fire
Rockets had there been three of
Muhammad's children were born in this
Siege they all show signs of
malnutrition and spend most of their
lives inside
of course I worry about the Muhammad
says this isn't a safe place I don't let
them go outside on their own in case
there are Rockets or anything
foreign
neither children nor pensioners are safe
I was shot in the back by a sniper her
home's right on the front line and she
refuses to be pushed out
I refuse to leave my house she tells us
I refuse to the houthis would shout at
me crazy woman leave your house that I
will never ever leave
the war has never let up in Taz and
whilst there's increasing optimism about
a negotiated settlement for the country
those hopes seem to have halted at the
gates of this city
just to give you an idea of how close
they all are living to the front line at
the end of that road is where the
fighting is no man's land and dozens of
families are living in this area they've
had to put up sheets to try and obscure
the view of the sniper who has
positioned himself just beyond there
it means constant exchanges between the
war in groups
we're defending our land and our
families one tells us
we want peace another says but they
don't want it they're killing innocent
people and children and that's why we
carry weapons
this intransigence has led to one of the
world's worst humanitarian disasters
with starvation poverty and disease in
the hospital Wards homes and streets of
Yemen
three-month-old ayad is holding on to
Life by a thread the youngest of six
who've all had the same battle to
survive in a country where her mother
has to choose between food or medicine
when she can pay for neither
my daughter was very weak and we needed
to take her to the hospital she explains
but we didn't have the money so we had
to wait to try to get someone by then
she was unconscious
those like Fatima want Justice too the
mother of nine knows more than most
about loss
they were kids not Fighters she's
talking about her children four of them
were blown up in one day three were
killed outright the fourth only a
toddler lost a leg
photos of their mutilated bodies are all
she's left of her babies
and she's praying for revenge for their
violent deaths
compiled a file with their details and
wants to track down those who fired the
mortar shell that killed them as they
were playing outside their home
nothing can ever replace my children she
says
they'll never come back look at these
pictures she keeps saying to us they're
just children
she's pregnant again but would have
aborted if doctors had agreed
she doesn't want to bring another child
into this war-torn place
foreign
has sweet tea with yesterday's bread
it's her first and only meal of the day
the tragic daily struggles there for
families living under siege in the city
of Taz one of the many tragedies of this
war is that the last 12 months were
supposed to be a real opportunity for
peace in Yemen a truce signed between
the houthi rebels and the government
forces should have ended the fighting
and laid the groundwork for talks
between the Rival parties and although
there is some hope for the future
civilians are still being killed and
injured daily Often by Minds
deliberately left behind by the houthi
rebels and that is a potential War crime
under international law so too of the
thousands and thousands of airstrikes by
the saudi-led Coalition which have
targeted schools markets homes and many
of these victims are children it is an
horrific and heartbreaking Legacy of War
uh uh the talk of Peace in Yemen doesn't
drown out the cries of the war victims
hutub's still a teenager but he's lost
both his hands and his sight and all
hope for a better future now
his body is peppered with shrapnel
wounds many still lodged in his chest
he doesn't seem aware of how severe his
injuries are and he won't be able to get
the specialist help he so urgently needs
inside Yemen
his father appeals to us to get his son
medical help he needs to go out of Yemen
he tells us he's a human there are lots
like him but look how he's suffering
they can't make artificial limbs quickly
enough to cope with a growing number of
amputees who need them now but creating
prosthetic legs are easy in comparison
to electronic hands which are very
expensive so they mostly do cosmetic
arms
yeah
it doesn't do anything
many of the amputees are children
there's a whole generation like Abdullah
growing up maimed and mutilated by this
long War
most of abdullah's 10 years have been
spent living in this war zone he still
has Ambitions to be a footballer and is
a Taekwondo enthusiast
but his life's going to be tough an
anti-explosive teams know he won't be
the last to suffer
how can I help my family and friends
Abdullah asks he doesn't want them to go
through the same pain
you can tell them if they see anything
suspicious do not touch it do not touch
anything
Anaya lost her leg during what was meant
to be an agreed truce between the
fighting groups the 13 year old has
learned how wartime agreements on no
agreements at all in Yemen
she shows us on her good leg how doctors
had to cut more and more of her wounded
limb to Stave off infection which still
hasn't healed seven months after the
explosion
her family's traumatized about the day
she got blown up by a landmine left in
the street
Anaya's since dropped out of school and
says she's no friends now either but she
still has dreams to get Justice for war
crimes
my dream is to be a lawyer she tells us
I was thinking I'd learn English and I
want to study to be a lawyer so I can
fight and defend those who need it
but first she's got her own fight on her
hands to heal and every five days she
comes here to get her wound cleaned
it's a constant tussle between nurse and
patient
keep your hand away he says
don't tell me what to do she screams
don't do that he says he's worried about
more infections
it hurts it hurts Anaya sobs it's
acutely painful and she's had seven
months of this pain
it's turned into a regular battle of
wills
but they are the best of friends
few believe she'll be the last of
Yemen's War wounded or it's really
nearing an end
[Music]
we're still in the middle of
the world not no peace is coming
it's depressing yeah or depressed here
everybody's depressed
there's still much insecurity here
despite a recent lull in fighting
Nationwide
the whole of Taz seems like it's one big
Minefield sometimes with civilians
living right in the middle of it all
there is a small yemeni team tasked with
clearing that their International
funding's been slashed as AIDS diverted
to conflicts like Ukraine often they
can't even afford the paint to show a
paths being checked
the Halo trust which gets some British
funds is now inside the city
and one of its priorities is warning
Children of the dangers of unexploded
Ordnance
many of the homes here are incubating
explosives which have yet to detonate
and the Halo trust will assess the risks
and aimed to remove what they can
starting in the next few weeks there is
a constant threat in this particular
neighborhood of items being fired from
that front line
I believe yesterday was the latest
incident that was a martyr which was
fired slightly further down in tawa
this war has torn apart lives and torn
off Limbs and the options are very
limited for survivors like ten-year-old
NADA and her older sister
not as considered lucky because she has
an artificial hand which she struggles
to put on to show off to us
when she finally manages it it's quickly
apparent it is more of a hindrance to
her
when I push my arm inside it feels
painful she says when my bone touches
the artificial bit
it's less than six months since her arm
was blown off and her new artificial
limb is already broken and utterly
useless
Nadia tells us she wanted to be a doctor
but she doesn't think she'll be able to
now with just one hand so she's aiming
to study to be a mind clearer
I don't want others to be affected like
I have and to go through what happened
to me she says that's why I tell my
siblings I'm going to be a mind
clearance woman
and not one of us who hears her doubts
she'll do exactly that
there isn't a single person in this
country who hasn't been affected by this
war and that it grinds on and on more
and more yemenis are demanding an end to
the fighting and calling for peace but
the space for these voices is being
eradicated with the authorities on both
sides clamping down on descent
journalists YouTubers women's rights
activists are all facing prison torture
even execution just for speaking their
minds we've managed to get access to
some of those at the Forefront of this
battle as they Risk Everything to demand
an end to the human rights Crackdown
the war is suspended for a Time inside
these art classes here they can express
themselves in a way which is a lot more
problematic outside
they paint their dreams
and their fears
but the themes of killing violence and
oppression are ever present
I drew myself in space away from all the
suffering where we are on earth she told
us the painting shows her looking out of
a window to a new peaceful world
but outside these walls people on both
sides of this conflict have told us of
serious violations of human rights
or men in the cage are YouTubers social
media bloggers who criticize the houthi
rebels in control in the north calling
them greedy and corrupt the houthis made
sure their court appearance was
broadcast on the channels they control
the YouTubers were jailed for between
six months and three years after being
found guilty of inciting chaos and
spreading false information
four journalists are still in jail and
facing execution eight years after being
accused of fake news and spying by the
houthis
another journalist in the same jail told
us he saw them being tortured and he was
too
much
the war has meant Yemen is becoming more
and more of a man's world with them
holding all the power
women living in the shadow of all these
guns told us of mounting worries and an
increasing lack of freedoms
every single woman here working or
getting outside his suffering she's
struggling she's facing too many
difficulties so she can get away or get
out of her home just to face the society
in the street every single morning
another said she'd been bullied and
threatened online after posting a
picture with a man her husband
there was a lot of Anger from everyone
she told us posts were sent to me full
of violence there was even a campaign by
religious figures but also from
journalists there was very little
acceptance that a woman and man should
be sharing these kinds of pictures she
told us
singers like this young woman are
discouraged derided and mocked
right now in this war she says
everything's really tough for us yemeni
artists there are loads of things which
make it hard for us women to sing
there's resistance from our families
it's against our customs and against our
Traditions so yemeni artists face a lot
of problems
[Music]
a model who posted videos on Tick Tock
and Instagram is now facing five years
in a houthi jail
her Instagram pictures without a hijab
caused outrage amongst the houthi de
facto authorities
she was accused of her moral Behavior
committing indecent acts and drug
possession the 20-year-old's jailing has
caused shock inside Yemen and Beyond and
underscored the huge challenge of
restoring human rights in the country
the brave women and men there refusing
to be silenced despite the risks
well the recent restoring of diplomatic
ties between Iran and Saudi Arabia has
brought us closer to possible peace than
ever before but the challenges which
remain are considerable International
Aid is being slashed placing even more
yemeni lives at risk the legacy of
unexploded Ordnance threatens hundreds
of thousands of civilians and the
proliferation of weapons amongst armed
groups means there is still so much that
needs to be done before this country can
ever see an end to war we've tried to
bring you as rounded a picture as
possible of what life is like right now
for yemenis and not just their hopes for
peace but their need for accountability
to bring those responsible for war
crimes and human rights abuses to
Justice one day our Sky News team on the
ground here in Yemen includes cameraman
Jake Britton who brought you those
staggering images Middle East editors
zanjafar and our yemeni producer Ahmed
baida and big thanks and much respect to
the dozens and dozens of yemeni
civilians who let us tell their stories
often at risk to themselves thanks for
watching
[Music]